we're gonna do a JK job interview yeah  welcome Justin let me ask you an  on-the-job question oh okay okay so you  know me and Joe own this place right you  come in here you see me going  I'm like opening the JK crash register  the money out right taking funds for  himself and then you're like all right  Joe comes in would you wrap me up I mean  by the street you're not supposed to you  know say the name but then truth will  reveal itself later so how does that  happen though I uh  but then also are you dishonest with  Jokers you know who stole the money that  Joe comes up what the [ __ ] how  a lot of pressure  stay out of it so you're Pro stealing I  gotcha  it's very interesting  that's three because you didn't tell me